right power no power every action is a  consequence you have to really take the  consequence regardless I'm sorry yeah  but that's kind of her point  every actions so what I'll say  and not in that scenario obviously I'm  not going to take owners of the man  because I'm I don't I'm not going to  trust a woman straight away because this  is the easiest way to get trapped and if  you've got something about you and if  you're worth anything then you're not  gonna you're gonna take some some steps  right but once again what you're doing  is you're you're not you're not placing  any blame on the women you're saying it  demand is everything when we don't have  the choice so if if the choice is taken  away from for most men then you can't  really put the blame firmly on on most  men so